When you started programming,
you used the XML visualizer.
The things you can do in the visualizer,
you can also do in Android Studio and
a lot, lot, lot more.
As such, Android Studio might
look a little bit complicated.
But to start making a application,
you actually only need to know
a few of the core functionalities.
So really don't worry if you don't
know what every single button does.
I still look things up, and
I sure don't know what every single
button in Android Studio does.
Okay, I'm going to go down here and
click the Text tab.
Looking at this middle part of the
screen, I want you to think of this as
being something similar to a document
editor such as Google Docs.
In Google Docs, you open a file,
and you edit that file.
In Android Studio, you open a project
which contains many files, and
you can edit any of the files
within the project.
If we go over here to the left-hand
side, we can see all the folders and
files that are inside of our project.
If I go over to a folder and click it,
it shows me the sub-folders.
If I double-click a file,
it opens a tab for that file.
Here's where you could edit the file.
And the tabs across are for switching
back and forth between different files.
I'm going to go ahead and
close this file that I just opened
by clicking the little x up here.
As you're editing things
in Android Studio,
it does the work of
automatically saving your work.
Now if I do something really disastrous,
like whoops,
I accidentally select all this and
then delete it,
always remember that you can undo and
redo in Android Studio.
I'm going to undo that by going
up here to the menu bar, and
clicking Edit > Undo.
And you can see right below
it that we have Redo.
Alternatively, if you don't
want to use the menu bar,
you can use the keyboard shortcut
Ctrl+Z, or on Macs, Cmd+Z.
And to redo, it's Cmd+Shift+Z or
Ctrl+Shift+Z.
Let's take a closer look
at the left-hand side here.
Everything here combined
makes up your app.
An app or an application on
Android isn't a single file.
It's a collection of images,
layouts, and other code.
Note that if you go up here,
you can select a few different ways to
view the files and folders in your app.
Project, in particular,
shows you what the folders actually
look like on your computer.
I'll click down a bit so you can see.
All right, not to scare you, but when
you made your app there's actually a ton
of folders and
files that were generated for you.
To simplify things, I usually just stick
with the Android view which is a little
easier to navigate.
Now back when you made your project,
you chose where the project
was going to be saved.
If you ever forget,
you can look up here at the menu bar,
which reminds you where
your project is saved.
And if you're feeling particularly
brave, you should feel free to even take
a peek at what this folder structure
actually looks like on your computer.
For example, on a Mac machine,
I could go to my home folder
> Android Studio Projects.
And then I see this
HappyBirthday folder,
and this contains all of the project
files and folders for the application.
So if I were to delete this folder or
move this folder,
it would really mess up things for
Android Studio.
Okay, so what we're going to be working
with is the activity_main.xml file.
It's located in the layout folder
because it contains XML that has
the design or
layout of your application.
I'm going to double-click.
Now the contents of this file
should look pretty familiar.
It's very, very similar to the sort of
XML that we were writing in the lesson.
One big difference are these
two attributes here.
The xmlns attribute says that
we're working with attributes that
are specific to Android development and
making layouts.
XML is also used with websites,
storing data, and other applications.
So we use this xmlns attribute to
specify that we're making things
particularly for Android development and
particularly for layouts.
The fact that we use the word Android
here is also the reason that we put
android: in front of all
the attributes that we use.
If you'd like to learn a little bit
more about the xmlns attribute,
you can check out the instructor notes.
The important thing to know is
when you make a new application,
these two things will be
automatically included.
And you should include them in
any other layouts you make,
otherwise your application won't work.
All right, now down here, you're going
to see two tabs, the Design tab and
the Text tab.
And the Text tab is actually the tab
that you're usually going to be
working with.
Over here on the far right, you'll see
that there's a button that says Preview.
If you click on it,
it'll remove the picture of the phone,
and if you click on it again, it'll
bring the picture of the phone back.
This is a preview of what your
XML looks like on a phone.
It's very similar to the XML Visualizer.
I'm actually going to go ahead and
change the text attribute here to say,
Goodbye World.
Now if you do this on your own machine
and you zoom in here, let me do it now,
you should see that the text updated
to say Goodbye World, pretty cool.
If you click on the Design tab,
you'll see a drag and drop interface for
designing phone layouts.
So for example, I could drag
things over into the application.
Over here in this area
called Component Tree,
it's going to list all of
the different views that I have.
If I click on a particular view,
down here in Properties, it shows me
all of the different attributes or
properties that I can change.
This list can be pretty helpful for
discovering new layout properties.
Also, if you right-click
on any of these properties,
such as this alignStart, it'll give you
an option to see the documentation.
This design view is pretty helpful if
you're trying to quickly build a layout.
But you get a lot more control over
exactly where different elements go
if you understand and
know how to write code.
Since we don't really need any of these
additional options, and don't know what
a lot of them do yet, it's easier
to just stick with the Text tab.
That concludes a quick
tour of Android Studio.
Next, we'll work on
running our first app.